hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online jungle now surely
you've already heard about the new star
in the world of cyber crime the hacker
group lapsis they made headlines for the
first time in december of 2021 when
hackers successfully attacked the
brazilian ministry of health the
criminals actually copied over
confidential information and demanded a
ransom from the government for its
non-disclosure and then in less than
three months 19 more large companies
became victims of lapses for example
hackers downloaded and published 190
gigabytes of data from samsung's
corporate network and after their attack
on microsoft the source code of some
modules of the bing search engine and
the cortana voice assistant appeared on
the network too lapses also hacked
nvidia they managed to steal the
accounts of 70 000 users of the company
and also download certificates
confirming the security of drivers and
software modules ubisoft and vodafone
also admitted that their corporate
networks were successfully attacked by
this group the hackers here behaved like
real rock stars they boasted about their
success in their telegram channel they
generously shared stolen information and
according to microsoft's experts didn't
make much effort to cover their tracks
at all it's not surprising therefore
that on the 24th of march the city of
london police detained seven alleged
members of lapses another thing was
quite surprising here they all turned
out to be under 21 years old the leader
of the group who was known on the
internet under the name of white docspin
was a 16 year old from oxford impressive
right we'll now imagine that there were
300 bitcoins in this guy's crypto wallet
and at that time they're worth more than
14 million dollars i bet in your head
you're already imagining some kind of
computer genius who writes code in his
mind and knows tens of thousands of
pages of operating system reference
books right well you'd actually be wrong
lapses is a new generation of hackers
after all in the year of 2022 hackers
don't actually have to be able to
program this is a screenshot from reddit
on a popular and publicly available
resource the author of the message
openly made an offer to employees of
mobile operators to help with hacking
clients of their companies you see the
message explicitly talks about sim swaps
now this is the name given to
transferring a mobile phone number to a
new sim card and this is a completely
normal and acceptable operation for
example if you lost your phone along
with the sim card or maybe you decided
to change your nokia 3310 to an iphone
13 right but the guys from lapsis were
interested in sim swapping to bypass
two-factor authentication and this was
far from the only announcement in open
sources hackers didn't even bother in
using proxy server chains data
encryption methods and all that i've
already talked about more than once
instead they actively used telegram and
exchanged messages on forums openly
however they still did actively use the
darknet to purchase stolen user data if
the user's data couldn't be bought labs
has tried to steal them with the help of
other people's programs which are not
difficult to find even in the open part
of the internet in the history of lapses
i was more interested in another
question are they the first no-code
hackers well it turns out that no not at
all after all the first hackers didn't
use computers at all
[Music]
what do you think the first ever hackers
did that's right they messed about with
model trains in november of 1946 two
students at mit founded the tech model
railroad club in those years many young
people were fond of these small model
trains but it was a very expensive past
time and therefore john fitzell and
moore and walter marvin decide to join
forces to share the costs in building a
unique mock-up of a railway on campus
their friends liked the idea and it
attracted several different teams in a
matter of months some students became
interested in creating miniature
buildings others in replicating real
trains and wagons but the most difficult
engineering task was faced by the
students who automated the work of the
model they tried to control things like
the movement of trains the switching of
arrows and the operation of semaphores
with the help of complex relay chains
students use parts from telephone
exchanges and spent hours developing
schemes for their connection it was then
that the word hack appeared in their
vocabulary it meant a kind of unusual
and elegant technical solution to a
problem
and soon the students ended up calling
each other hackers and a few years later
this word was adopted by their friends
who worked with the first ever computers
by the early 60s the layout of the
railway was controlled by a system of
1200 relays and routes and train
schedules were calculated in advance
using a real mainframe the layout has
survived to this day however now it's
controlled by four dozen
microcontrollers so if you're at mit
make sure to take a look at this
masterpiece
unfortunately the founder and first
president of tmrc is rarely remembered
when talking about the first ever
hackers but john moore did go down in
history as the creator of the world's
first ct scanner i wonder how many hacks
from this railway layout were used in
this device so look as you can see
initially the word hacker didn't carry
any negative connotations at all in the
60s you had to save every bit of memory
you could every clock cycle of the
process and therefore non-standard
tricks helped to squeeze more out of
computers than their creators could ever
imagine every time i think about that
era this photograph of margaret hamilton
appears before my eyes this girl is a
real hacker from mit and in this picture
she poses with one of the most famous
programs of the 20th century this huge
stack of paper is a print out of the
software for the apollo 11 spacecraft
for the first time in history margaret
thought about ensuring the
ultra-reliable operation of computers a
significant part of the code consists of
things like error recognition and
correction algorithms and margaret's
caution here actually saved the lives of
neil armstrong and buzz aldrin let me
explain
three minutes before landing on the moon
the computer began to receive incorrect
signals from the radar which monitored
the position of the module remaining in
orbit this information was ultimately
needed to return to orbit in case of say
a termination of the landing errors
began to accumulate and threatened to
take up the tiny memory of the computer
but the hamilton program recognized the
critical situation and warned the
astronauts about it with the historic
alarm 1202
the computer turned off the process and
solved this problem of ram overflow this
was a giant leap for a computer whose
ram was about four kilobytes
tranquility we copy you on the ground
you got a bunch of guys about to turn
blue we're breathing again thanks a lot
now you can still appreciate the beauty
of this program today five years ago
enthusiasts posted it on github if
you're down with assembly code you can
find the link in the description do you
remember a few years ago if you would
type a few characters in the indian
language telugu into your iphone it
would cause it to reboot
well the cortex system was to blame here
which was responsible for displaying
unusual characters on the screen this
sequence of glyphs forced the system to
try to do what it literally could not do
display a non-existent symbol and
created an infinite number of graph
themes as a result
cortex quickly started using all of the
free amounts of ram the phone tried to
close the dangerous process and closed
the phone's desktop as a result but back
to the history of hackers while some
dreamed of the moon others were just
looking for vulnerabilities in our
surroundings what do you think an
automatic telephone exchange and
cornflakes might have in common
frequency
in 1970 the computer world was ruled by
huge and expensive mainframes there were
still five years left by the way before
the experience of the first alta 8800
personal computer only 13 nodes were
connected to arpanet which would turn
into the internet some years later
telephone lines therefore remained the
main means of communication but
conversations between different cities
in america were not cheap and of course
people tried to cheat the phone
companies the first example of this was
done by a five-year-old child joseph
carl ingressia was blind from birth the
physical disadvantage was compensated by
fine musical ear one day joseph heard
strange sounds in telephone receiver
with their help the phone and the
automatic telephone exchange traded
service signals so the system received
information about the end of the
conversation and gave permission to make
a long distance call joseph learned to
simulate these high frequency signals
and at the right moment he whistled into
the phone and got one opportunity to
chat with pretty much anyone all over
the country for free
in the late 60s whilst he was in college
joseph shared his secret with his
friends and soon information about his
unusual abilities attracted the
attention of telephone companies fbi
agents and even the press
young people across the country started
to experiment with their phones they
tried to record service signals using
tape recorders and we're looking for
ways to simulate such signals
unexpectedly and here's where cornflakes
comes in the simplest tool for this
became a children's toy this is the boat
swain's pipe which was found enclosed in
boxes of cap and grunge cornflakes by
coincidence the pipe made a sound at a
frequency of 2600 hertz the same
frequency was coincidentally used by a t
to indicate that a trunk line was
available for routing a new call and
this made it possible to you guessed it
make free calls and this is how a
plastic toy gave way to the freakers
movement now this word is derived from a
combination of the words freak and
frequency in october 1971 an article by
rosen rosenbaum titled secrets of the
little blue box was published in esquire
magazine and this article is based on an
interview with john draper who created
one of the first electronic devices that
aims to mimic the tone signals of
telephone exchanges first thing i would
do is i would blow
this
draper quickly became a star of the
freaker's movement and subsequently got
charged with fraud in 1972 the court
found him guilty and sentenced him to a
suspended sentence of five years but
this didn't discourage draper at all and
he continued sharing his knowledge with
other enthusiasts in particular with
steve jobs and steve wozniak
in those years the future founders of
apple tried to establish their own
production of blue boxes draper would
continue to collaborate with jobs and in
76 he would work on a system for
connecting the apple ii to telephone
lines and in 1979 he'd write the first
word processor for this very computer
freakers became the first ever scammers
who used their knowledge to benefit from
the illegal use of complex electronic
systems their ideology and way of
thinking became the basis for the
division of hackers into white hats and
black hats
[Music]
by the early 80s personal computers were
no longer something of a curiosity
thousands of people across america were
becoming interested in programming and
exploring the possibilities of the first
ever computer networks the spirit of the
era was personified by a new hero neil
patrick at just 17 he appeared on the
cover of newsweek magazine gave an
interview with phil donohue and became a
guest of cbs morning news neil was the
voice of hacker group 414 414 never
tried to cover its tracks even the name
contributes to their de-anonymization
the founders of the group live in
milwaukee and 4-1-4 is just the phone
code of their area doesn't it sound a
lot like lapses only the 414s never
considered themselves criminals at all
their activities weren't aimed at making
profits they didn't try to transfer
money from someone else's account or
steal confidential information they were
just interested in the opportunities
that new technologies could open up and
within just one year hackers were
bypassing the security systems of
pacific national bank and even the
nuclear laboratory in los alamos the
hackers of course acted carelessly
during the hacking of the
sloan-kettering cancer center they
accidentally deleted part of the
accounting documentation the clinic
estimated damage to be around 1 500
and of course in our times it's not much
money but this incident is what made it
possible for federal authorities to
arrest the hackers at that time there
were no laws against hacking so adult
participants of 414 were charged with
telephone hooliganism at what point did
you first question the ethical propriety
of what you were doing once the fbi
directed at my door
they were threatened with two years of
probation and a fine of 500 but in the
end the charges against the hackers were
dropped altogether the story of the 414s
draws public attention to computer
security issues governments of different
countries ended up drafting various laws
aimed at countering cyber crime
developers and engineers in large
companies began learning how to
counteract intruders if they used to
struggle with the limitations of their
own computers now the main problem is
the malicious intent of other people in
classic westerns good heroes could be
distinguished from the criminals by the
color of their hats the officers of the
law wore white while the bandits wore
black in the digital world black hats
seek to gain illegal access to other
people's systems most often for the sake
of money and power white hats on the
other hand help companies identify
weaknesses in their systems and protect
themselves and others from black hats
in the 90s the gap between the opposing
camps grew there were more and more
computers hundreds of thousands of new
users began connecting to the network
and journalists subsequently began to
frighten ordinary people with the
horrors of digital world and hollywood
studios were shooting more and more
films the main characters of which were
computer criminals
get away from the computer
what did you think you were trying to do
save the world no not the world just
myself
at this point in time the income of
black cats was already measured in the
hundreds of thousands for example in
1993 kevin paulsen hacked into a
computer with which a radio station in
los angeles held contests with its
listeners kevin manipulated the results
and twice received the main prizes a
porsche 944 who didn't dream of such a
cool car as a child imagine how
paulson's story resonated in the hearts
of boys all over america and most of
them didn't want to spend hours learning
how to program thousands of teenagers
were looking for easy ways to become
hackers quickly so a new kind of hacker
began to appear in the digital jungle
the script kiddie this name was used to
describe low skilled malicious users
they used scripts and utilities written
by other people to attack other people's
networks and programs often a script
kitty or a skiddy doesn't even
understand how these scripts work but
it's simple enough for them to just
download the first program they find on
the web and carry out everything exactly
according to the instructions unlike
conventional hackers regardless of
whether they're white or black our
script kitty is not looking for new
knowledge at all they're not interested
in how the network works they need a
result and they need it here and now it
doesn't have to be money or a valuable
prize often it's just enough for them to
hack a random website on the web and
upload their nickname to its main page
funny
actually no not really the us's
department of defense's script kiddie
reports described it as the more
immature but unfortunately often just as
dangerous exploiter of security lapses
on the internet in 2015 a british vpn
provider conducted a curious experiment
the company's specialists asked a
seven-year-old betsy davies to try and
hack a public wi-fi hotspot now the girl
spent 10 minutes and 57 seconds to find
the necessary video tutorial on youtube
and then she was able to replicate it
completely as a result she managed to
raise a fake access point and carry out
a classic man in the middle attack to
intercept traffic from a participant's
laptop now of course naivety and
inexperience often play against such
hackers under the guise of combat
programs they often download viruses and
trojans that steal their own data or as
happened with the popular torrent client
they're engaged in work for their
creators they mine cryptocurrency or
become an element of a bot network in
defense of the script kitty i must say
that for some it's only a transitional
stage the first step on the path to a
real hacker by the way do you know what
kevin paulsen is doing now well he
continues to inspire novice hackers but
in a completely different way in 1991 he
was arrested for telephone fraud and
sentenced to five years in prison but
after that paulson became one of the
most famous it journalists in the world
as the editor of wired magazine
[Music]
in the 2010s more and more software
manufacturers began to move away from
selling their products in boxes towards
the ideology of software as a service or
saas for short cloud data storage photo
and video editing tools after all do you
remember the last time used offline
tools to work with texts the model of
buying a service rather than a license
has conquered the business community and
investors of course hackers didn't stay
away here either attackers have learned
how to make money by selling their
services using the sas model now it's
enough to make a couple of requests to
google to get access to modern
marketplaces where you'll be offered
access to tools for attacking
competitors
labor exchanges for hackers or detailed
instructions on hacking other people's
resources for instance with the help of
such services non-professionals are able
to organize attacks that far exceed
their qualifications novice cyber
criminals now just need to have the
desire and some money in order to
say perform a ddos attack block someone
else's phone hack an account create a
phishing site or even launch a unique
kind of virus you know the most unusual
thing that i came across when i was
looking for materials for this video is
the existence of ransomware programs
that work according to an sas model and
require only a percentage of the ransom
received it's a good business
considering that in 2020 the average
size of the buyer was about 170 000
however even with the help of such
services you obviously won't just become
a hacker the hacker's path is a constant
study of the world around him the search
for unusual moves and unlocked doors
this is a way of thinking and the
ability to compare facts to hear the
tone of a control signal on a children's
whistle to watch how the letters of a
complex alphabet can disable a
smartphone and learn how to control
trains using even mechanical relays in
any case my name is bradley and thanks
for tuning in to our weekly show here at
sumsup i will see you in the next video
thanks for joining us
[Music]